[Music]
foreign
there were quite a few monsters seen in
the new monsterverse trailer the Netflix
Skull Island series there has also been
a poster release which showcases a
couple more monsters that weren't seen
in a trailer so let's get to describing
the 12 creatures we saw in both of them
including the leaked scenes from kdm's
profile so let's get to it firstly of
course Khan the king of Skull Island he
is here in the show or else it'll be a
random animated series about a group of
Shipwrecked people fighting for survival
against random monsters come here seems
to be growing a beard and therefore this
story would be set somewhere between the
1970s and King of the Masters where the
island was trapped in a Perpetual storm
brought in by the bad Titan camazods
gone here would be of a greater size but
since it is animated it would not be
that pronounced
secondly the Maya squid the first
Monster to be seen in the trailer when a
Sikorsky Navy helicopter was slowly
approaching the island on a rescue
mission tentacles of this gigantic squid
with then snatch the helicopter midair
and break it into two ruining the
chances of a Quick Escape for the people
stuck in Skull Island
then next we have the siren jaw so this
one is the bipedal crocodile monster
that was seen hunting the Trap survivors
in the island although it isn't really
confirmed yet as to what kind of
creature it is we do know though that
there is already a crocodile monster in
Skull Island called the siren jaw but
this one seems to be smaller in size and
lacks the floral outgrowths as well as
being bipedal
the fourth one swarm Locus so yeah this
one is seen in the poster of the series
the one on the bottom right which is
green in color swarm Locus are insecto
gaijus that are Ambush Predators around
20 to 28 feet or 6 to 8.5 meters long
yeah I'm still a little bit iffy about
this one too but evidence pushes me to
this conclusion but I still could be
wrong it could be another new monster
next we have the skull crawler of course
the skull crawlers are going to be seen
in the series even though it did not
make an appearance in the trailer it is
seen though in the poster in the bottom
left these are a Mainstay in the most
diverse shows and rightly so they're
hyper carnivorous and aggressive
behavior as well as Sleek but scary
design does provoke a thrill when seen
in the screens
next we have the phoenix bird so even
though we have seen Leaf Wings on psycho
vultures in the birth of gong Comics the
skylighted movies and the kingdom Kong
Comics this is the first time we see a
new flying creature that looks like it
came straight out of a fantasy game and
also in Skull Island it looks like a
bird of prey but as large as an extinct
quential koalas and it is covered in red
as well as having sharp talons it does
look like a phoenix
then we have a chimera we also see a
mammalian creature that looks like a
cross between a lion a bulldog and
having specs on the back like an
Ankylosaurus this Beast is a chimera
which means it is a mix of different
creatures in one which of course can be
said the same about many other Skull
Island animals however this animal is
the Mount of an Eevee local that writes
it like a bell stallion
number 8 a crab monster this crustacean
monster is seen in the trailer as it
emerges from beneath the Sands in the
beach to capture human and that came too
close to its hiding spots it is bluish
green in color with very red pincers and
legs it also had a pair of red eyes a
large mouthful teeth and four mandibles
and lastly two pair of antenna we can
infer that this crap is an ambush
predator
next we have the cave humanoid seen
briefly in the trailer immediately after
the scene of the crab monster this scary
looking humanoid creature has four
yellowish glowing eyes and a mouthful of
teeth and four mandibles it seems to be
reptilian and insectoid in design with a
hand that has five fingers but a very
oddly shaped head it also had dark
grayish coloration to blend in with the
rocky habitat the 10th monster an
unidentified tentacle monster now when
you look at the poster you would see two
or maybe even three types of tentacles
and we all know what the Maya squids
look like if you look closely there are
those tentacles that I have what looks
like to be an arrowhead ending which
means that it is a different species and
if so will it be a rival to the Maya's
quit or even a full-scale Titan that
will fight the larger Kong on the show
number 11 the Shell Monster there was
another monster that was seen in the
leaked scenes of the series and this
creature resembles kind of like a
centipede but as large as a small
elephant and it had a shell on its back
it also had many pencil-like legs and on
the back there was a shell which
resembles kind of like a shell of a sea
snail it was also fast and movement able
to dodge even gunfire
number 12 the giant dodo lastly also
seen in the leaked scenes there was a
giant flightless bird kind of looking
like a Dodo that attacked the humans on
the island this was however killed by
the Bulldog lion the Chimera this giant
flightless bird was bluish in color
unlike the phoenix bird and was able to
run like an ostrich or an emu it could
be a descendant of a harambe Titan an
extinct predatory flightless bird
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam